the Joe Rogan experience euros upon
leave with a verse checkout
hit me with what's the logistics is my
egotistic personality part of my
coexistence or is it just the dangerous
stranger paying me an uninvited visit
like an unwanted Christmas guest or is
it just a fragment of my lowest self
envy greed and lust or my higher self
goodwill love and trust is this therapy
- I'm therapeutic to discuss I was
dangling in the dirt like a pair of
loose shoe strings but I was born in the
USA like Bruce Springsteen torn between
the temptation of bringing the ruckus -
maintaining a structure - keeping girls
on my payroll that cuts your nuts off
after they [ __ ] you before you've
ruptured they're trying to put me in a
quiet place with a word stop or put me
in a clothes pin space ruin life through
a bird box but close the windows shut
the doors
scattered ooh on the floor so the sound
of my footsteps aren't dampening his orb
that's a metaphor - kill the noise while
they walk around we look blindfolded as
they kill our boys and these crazy race
is wrong with cold still and they killed
for joy blood spills inside the church
and outside the shopping store inside
the movie theater school campus in
church or the synagogue's no location is
omitted most cases get acquitted by
mental illness and no guns are
prohibited is it rational to think this
is a national problem therefore is a
threat to national security and the
National Guard's needs to solve it or is
it visible it's a problem of individuals
who are not in court with the principle
of one nation under God indivisible
respect my veterans
[Applause]